[Musique]
où
bon raymond lucas quand lille a pris son
côté les calculs folie fait une affaire
et moi la vouli occupe au moins donne
piedoie la réunion du patrimoine
floristique et aussi sur le savoir-faire
populaire de nos aïeux nous remontent à
l'association en février 1996
l'association c'est la pnc les amis des
plantes et de la nature
notre mission c'est sauver nous pilbois
pays pour assurer la sauvegarde de notre
patrimoine floristique et pousse à nous
la trouvons un seul remède s'est fait
connaître
on nous l'a remarqué qu'une des club
icaunais norway sa boutique il réveille
en lui et lui fini par m le plan protège
la plante et c'est y trouve un petit
grain pour planter et assurer la
sauvegarde ou de pic bois si nous
plantent les enfants varrault voir ses
pieds de bois là aujourd'hui
nos associations les sollicité par les
communes par les établissements
scolaires par le nfd structure
officielle par le parc national
[Musique]
1 l'amour de sa bouffe et de la ténacité
si où il peut argumenter justifier sa
coupe et fonce frais ali et sa vie
musicale et la ténacité li na na
[Musique]
le coup n'est nulle a besoin c'est que
les colliers de nouilles participe aussi
à faire connaître aux marmailles zot
environnement originel est naturel que
les à côtés john gotti découvre haute
île aux autres pays
zohra vinh saute forêt aux pieds de bois
et ce à l'école il peut aide à nous on
ne peut pas sauver un patrimoine
si on plante pas